être édition spéciale continue on va
maintenant se concentrer sur les dégâts
humains et matériels de ces nuits de
violence et sur la réponse judiciaire
près de 3200 et Métiers interpellés
quels sont les premières peines
prononcer la sévérité réclamée par le
garde des sceaux est-elle mise en œuvre
c'est un sujet signé Renault parquet
après si lui des mœux turbaines les
tensions semblent s'être quelque peu
apaisés 150 personnes ont été
interpellées au cours de la nuit
dernière
297 véhicules ont été incendies et trois
membres des forces de l'ordre blessés
des chiffres qui ne montrent pas encore
une fin des tensions mais un
ralentissement de ces dernières un bilan
provisoire donc tout comme la calmi à
mettre en perspective car depuis la mort
du jeune mineur de 17 ans mardi dernier
l'embrasement des violences
3164 interpellations ont été conduites
700 membres des forces de l'ordre ont
été blessés et 1000 bâtiments ont été
dégradés au brûlés assez destructions ou
détériorations viennent s'ajouter les
5000 voitures détruites les dégradations
de services de transport en commun et de
la voie publique de son côté le Garde
des Sceaux a réclamé une réponse
judiciaire ferme et rapide
j'ai demandé des déferlements
systématiques j'ai demandé effectivement
que les procureurs requièrent des
mesures de sûreté de l'emprisonnement
pour être clair chaque fois qu'on s'en
prend aux personnes bien sûr je rappelle
qu'il y a beaucoup de blessés parmi les
forces de l'ordre parmi les élus je
rappelle que un vigile a failli brûler
vif au tribunal de proximité d'Asnières
où je me suis rendu que des agents
pénitentiaires ont été victimes de tir
et qu'ils ne doivent leur vie et leur
salut qu'à l'épaisseur d'une vitre donc
tout cela ce sont des crimes et qui
peuvent être qualifiés de cette façon
j'ai demandé une réponse ferme et
également une réponse ferme pour les
atteintes au bien les plus graves depuis
le début des émeutes 570 personnes ont
été déférées et 260 sont en comparution
immédiate les peines prononcées des
heures de travaux d'intérêt général à de
la peine de prison mais si les
comparutions immédiates permettent une
tenue d'audience rapide elle concerne
que les adultes alors que près d'un
tiers des ametiers sont des mineurs ces
procédures accélérées pourraient bien
avoir l'effet inverse de celui escompté
dans l'émotion dans la précipitation il
peut se produire effectivement que
certains policiers attrapent des jeunes
qui n'ont pas à participer directement
aux émeutes qui n'ont pas participé
directement aux scènes de pillage auquel
on a pu assister ou à la destruction de
bien c'est le rôle des avocats de
pointer du doigt les carences les
éventuelles d'un dossier qui a pu être
monté par le parquet et de faire jouer
tout un toute une sorte de nullité ou
alors de moins du moins de demander la
relax puisque dans certains cas les
éléments ne suffisent pas à caractériser
l'infraction pénale la grève des
greffiers qui débute aujourd'hui
pourraient ralentir toujours un peu plus
les audiences et procédures de justice à
un moment où le garde des sceaux
souhaite remettre les pendules à l'heure
la réponse judiciaire les dégâts humains
et matériels les causes de ces violences
en en débat tout de suite avec Jacques
de Maillard bonsoir bienvenue bonsoir
vous êtes directeur du centre de
recherche sociologique sur le droit et
les institutions pénales professeur de
sciences politiques à l'université
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
Jean Gary bonsoir vous êtes historien
président du comité de l'histoire
parlementaire auteur de Elysée contre
Matignon aux éditions Taillandier Thomas
Sauvadet bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
vous êtes sociologue maître de
conférence à l'Université Paris Est
Créteil et Mathieu croissanto éditoris
politique est resté à mes côtés je
commence sur la réponse judiciaire on
vient de voir ce ce reportage en
ouverture de ce de ce second débat elle
se veut ferme et dissuasive est-ce que
d'abord on voit que c'est pas si facile
à mettre en oeuvre Jacques de Mayer
est-ce que ça peut freiner les émeutiers
on l’évoquait tout à l'heure mais est-ce
que c'est vraiment dissuasif
si voilà on entend une petite musique
qui dit attention les les procureurs les
tribunaux sont plus sévères que
d'habitude
plus sévère que d'habitude ça il faut le
voir mais en tous les cas la sévérité
habituelle est déjà élevée donc
ça peut constituer un élément de
dissuasion bon quand on voit 600
personnes déférées 200 personnes qui
passent en comparution immédiate sans
doute des peines de prison ferme enfin
au-delà de l'effet dissuasif qui est
potentiel il y a tout simplement des
gens qui sont retirés de la rue alors
qu'ils étaient actifs donc oui on peut
imaginer que cette réponse pénale et des
effets je crois qu'il faut être
effectivement attentif notamment pour
les plus jeunes à ce que cette justice
là soit pas une justice trop rapide
alors les mineurs ne comparaissaient pas
en immédiatement ça fait uniquement
c'était uniquement comparaître en
comparution mécaniquement à partir de 18
ans il y a beaucoup Jean Gary de jeux de
jeunes interpellés qui qui ont participé
à des pillages et qui dit bah c'était
ouvert j'ai fait comme tout le monde je
me suis servi qu'est-ce que ça qu'est-ce
que ça vous inspire
ce que ça m'inspire c'est que d'abord
moi j'inscris malgré tout cette ce qui
se passe cette explosion des banlieues
qui est pas la première parce que ça
fait 40 ans depuis Vénissieux qui a des
explosions de ce type elle est
exceptionnelle est-ce qu'il y a pas un
cran de violence supplémentaire
dans cette généalogie et en me disant
évidemment ça correspond à un certain
nombre de facteurs sociologiques etc
donc il faut prendre en compte mais en
me disant aussi que c'est très adapté
justement à l'époque et que par exemple
le fait que ça soit parti en flamme et
un peu partout beaucoup plus vite qu'en
2005 et une contagion nationale d'une
tentation nationale est liée notamment
aux réseaux sociaux à la force des
réseaux sociaux à la diffusion de toutes
sortes de médias qui qui vont dans le
sens de cette de cette diffusion et puis
dans une évolution aussi des mentalités
de notre société en général dans une
forme de
comment dire ça de détachement de ce de
tous les codes de toutes les de tous les
carcans de tous les pouvoirs de tous les
c'est-à-dire tous les rites de de notre
société alors y compris de voilà de de
piller comme ça des magasins et cetera
c'est pas nouveau ça c'est déjà produit
mais c'est quelque chose qui correspond
à une sorte de désagrégation de d'un
tissu social alors ça se passe
aujourd'hui dans ce qu'on appelle les
quartiers dans les banlieues mais cette
désagrégation là ce manque j'allais dire
de respect pour la propriété privée par
exemple c'est quelque chose qui qui est
en train de toucher toute la société
enfin Thomas soda est-ce que les des
bandes qui peuvent tenir un quartier des
points de Deal est-ce que elles sont à
l'oeuvre depuis presque une semaine
après vous oui c'est un classique sur
les 40 dernières années dans notamment
les quartiers de la boutique de la ville
les bandes de jeunes qui représentent à
peu près 10% des jeunes de moins de 30
ans en gros entre 10 et 30 ans donc ça
ça fait à peu près une cinquantaine une
centaine voire 200 jeunes par quartier
sont les acteurs principaux en fait de
ces émeutes depuis le début des années
et donc ils ont une expérience du
rapport de force avec la police
on parle souvent de ce rapport de force
mais il y a aussi un rapport de force
avec le voisinage ils ont aussi eu dans
le quotidien des tensions importantes
avec les commerçants les acteurs
associatifs
qui souvent sont obligés de reculer de
ne pas voir de se taire pour ne pas
avoir de problèmes donc ils ont pris une
place démesurée aujourd'hui dans
beaucoup de qpv il y en a 1200 en France
voilà 1200 en France métropolitaine ils
ont pris une place très très importante
et il y a des différentes formes de
radicalisation en fait de cette jeunesse
après autour vous avez donc là vous
décrivez un phénomène général mais ma
question c'était est-ce que ces bandelas
sont clairement à l'oeuvre depuis six
jours oui oui bien sûr les acteurs
principaux en fait des émeutes après
autour de cette de cette jeunesse qui a
une expérience en fait vraiment de du
rapport de force et de l'affrontement
vous avez et c'est ce qui change aussi
depuis enfin c'est une influence de plus
en plus importante de ces bandes par
rapport à la jeunesse en général ce qui
fait que vous avez des jeunes dans ces
quartiers et même dans les quartiers
pavillonnaires des environs qui sont pas
dans ces bandes qui sont pas voilà mais
qui regarde ce qui se passe qui imite
qui vivent leur crise d'adolescence avec
ce registre des codes des bandes des qpv
qui écoutent la même musique qui copie
c'est le style vestimentaire et qui
participent notamment avec les réseaux
sociaux de ses émeutes aussi donc on a
pour moi on a deux catégories en fait de
des métiers dans les émeutes de ces
derniers jours votre avis là-dessus
Jacques de Maya disons que dans la
logique des
contagion lente quoi ou de vous voyez ce
que je veux dire de oui c'est ça de
mimétisme oui ça ça a joué
en tête mais c'est un peu ça vous voyez
ce que je veux dire c'est tant de
coordination que de de concurrence
mimétiques ça ça a pu jouer il y a des
motifs très variables dans l'engagement
dans les émeutes qui peut aller de la
colère au jeu voir au pillage mais je
dirais qu'il y a quand même une toile de
fond qui est à mon avis de deux ordres
défaut souligner
la première c'est que cette colère elle
s'inscrit dans une logique
ségrégationniste en fait au sein de la
société française de durcissement des
différences dans ces quartiers là qui
fait que des jeunes qui sont à Laval à
Clermont-Ferrand à Clichy-sous-Bois ou à
Nanterre peuvent se retrouver et donc
cet enjeu là il est général il est
prégnant et le second c'est quand même
très étonnant à certains égards c'est
que après les émeutes de 2005 on aurait
pu penser ce qui est commun avec les
émeutes de 2005 c'est que ça part d'un
incident avec la police et que ça
démarre très très fort pourquoi parce
que dans les multiples raisons la colère
le sentiment d'injustice des expériences
partagées de tension quotidienne
d'hostilité retenue de familiarité
perverses avec les forces de l'ordre et
quand même très prégnant chez ces jeunes
là et en fait on aurait pu penser que la
aurait pu en tenir compte dans la façon
d'interagir d'être présent dans les
quartiers d'avoir une présence plus
rassurante plus paisible plus au service
de la population et en définitive 18 ans
après qui a été quand même le moment
principal des meutes en France on fait
le constat qui a pas eu de changement
décisif dans les façons de faire la
police au contraire il y a même eu le
lundi de proximité qui a été mise de
côté depuis 2003
et on est souvent dans ces quartiers là
dans une logique du trou du pas assez
c'est-à-dire du trop c'est à dire la
police qui vient dans une moment de
d'interpellation de projection très
nombreuses ou qui est pas assez présente
dans son rôle de protection sur une
prise en quotidienne et ça renvoie quand
même à une difficulté structurelle de ce
point de vue là avec là là on est dans
le temps de l'interpellation évidemment
je vous redonne des chiffres à 3164
interpellations depuis mercredi soir
sont les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur on a voulu comparer
justement parce qu'on a tous en tête les
précédentes 2005 2005 il y avait eu 5200
interpellations mais trois semaines donc
là on est vraiment dans là aussi dans un
dans un niveau
supplémentaire Jean Gary avec donc la
contagion dont on vous parliez tout à
l'heure et puis avec là le temps qui est
d'abord le temps de l'urgence et de la
réponse sécurité mais il va falloir une
autre réponse après oui alors dans la
relation police jeunesse c'est certain
mais c'est ce que vous disiez est-ce que
ça sera possible pardon je vais au bout
de ma question parce que ce qui se passe
là depuis une semaine c'est du
ressentiment en
graine qui qui peut germer encore dans
les prochains mois dans les prochaines
années il y a aussi ce risque là quoi
d'ailleurs
depuis quelques années on voit bien ce
radicaliser ce polariser cette
opposition entre une partie il faut
quand même toujours le dire une minorité
de ces jeunes dans les banlieues parce
que la majorité elle est tranquille elle
essaye de vivre sa vie une minorité et
puis et puis la police et c'est vrai que
des deux côtés il y a cette forme de
montée vers la radicalisation on voit
les syndicats de police le discours des
syndicats de police aujourd'hui il est
beaucoup plus dur encore que qui a
quelques années enfin moi j'ai lu des
choses qui étaient quand même très très
surprenantes
dans dans les heures qu'on suivent la
mort de Maëlle il y a un syndicat de
police qui minoritaire et pèse 3% mais
quand même qui se distingué
incroyables et donc vous effectivement
alors qu'on aurait pu attendre justement
une des politiques de de rapprochement
dans ces banlieues avec des comment dire
cette construction d'une forme de contre
société liée au trafic qui justement
renforce ce sentiment de à la fois de de
radicalité et puis de et puis
d'opposition aux valeurs et aux
institutions de la République il
faudrait aller les chercher justement
aller chercher ceux qui ne sont pas ceux
qui sont susceptibles de ne pas tomber
dans ce dans ce clan j'allais dire de
quartier j'entends ça mais Thomas Suez
si on se met à la place des policiers je
dis pas qu'il y a il y a certainement du
racisme dans dans la police comme il y
en a dans la société française il y a
sur l'usage des armes à feu on l'a vu
malheureusement avec ce qui s'est passé
à Nanterre il y a des il y a beaucoup de
choses à dire mais on peut se mettre
aussi du côté des policiers qui doivent
travailler dans ces quartiers confronté
aux bandes dont vous parliez aux
insultes quotidiennes etc je leur
cherche pas des excuses mais je cherche
à comprendre la situation oui c'est
compliqué vous avez bon sur les 1200 qpv
vous avez
différents niveaux de de de de tension
mais vous avez clairement aujourd'hui
certains qpv ou c'est quasiment
impossible d'intervenir
sans sans des renforts sans une
intervention très rapide
vous avez donc le lien dont parlait
Jacques de Mayer tout à l'heure on se
dit c'est quasiment impossible de le
renouer dans ces quartiers là de toute
façon entre les bandes de entre les
bandes de jeunes et la police c'est un
grand classique que ça soit même à
l'époque des blousons noirs on avait le
plein emploi on avait des blousons noirs
à Montreuil il y a des documentaires qui
sont encore disponibles sur Youtube on
voit des blousons noirs ils ont pas
sortir de notre quartier sans être
contrôlé par la police dire c'est que ça
soit les Apaches au début du 20e siècle
c'est un grand classique en fait donc le
la question c'est la place de ces
groupes si elle est de plus en plus
importante dans les quartiers c'est
c'est bien sûr un problème pour la
population et aussi pour la police et
les interventions d'accord n'oubliez pas
que vous avez sur certains quartiers
comme on l'a vu par exemple à Marseille
comme on l'a vu aussi en
Île-de-France à des fois un bloc un
blocus total dire que les routes sont
coupées à Marseille vous avez eu
certains quartiers avec des checkpoints
bien sûr il faut se rendre compte
10% de la population la plus jeune dans
un quartier moi je me demande toujours
et j'ai pas la solution mais pourquoi on
arrive pas à finalement faire en sorte
qu'ils arrêtent de nuire et de pourrir
la vie de des 90% d'autres Matthieu
c'est parce que le rapport entre police
et cette jeunesse là et enfin je parle
pas des délinquants masculin mais la
jeunesse de ces quartiers populaires ou
qpv comme vous dites c'est un impensé
politique de la part de nos gouvernants
il y a personne ne s'y attelé ça a
commencé on est forcément dans un débat
qui est vicié parce que la gauche est
par nature accusé d'être laxiste et la
droite demande toujours plus de
répression après c'est de 2005 et
souvent on a quand même un Nicolas
Sarkozy qui dit moi je vais vous en
débarrasser de cette racaille au soleil
l'exemple est donné en haut de terme
aussi aussi des racailles enfin c'est
c'est des ordures c'est voilà c'est
c'est comme si c'était des détritus j'ai
quand l’exemple est donné en haut c'est
sûr que la police qui travaille déjà
dans des conditions très hostiles dans
ces quartiers va pas commencer à t'y
servir on a supprimé la police de
proximité et puis et puis la gauche
c'est jamais non plus attelé à clé à ce
problème et dernière chose Michel
zeckler producteur de musique vous
souvenez il se fait tabasser par des
policiers c'est après ça Emmanuel Macron
dit je vais lancer un beau veau de la
sécurité justement pour rapprocher pour
travailler sur ce malaise entre la
population et la police c'est devenu un
chantier sur le malaise dans la police
et pas tellement dans le malaise
population la police alors on va il y a
deux aspects d'abord la effectivement la
réponse politique je vous propose une
réaction qui date de cette fin
d'après-midi puisque les présidents de
groupe parlementaires étaient reçus à
Matignon à la demande
d'Elizabeth borne en écoute Bruno
retaillant le président du groupe lr.o
Sénat qui est qui réclame plus de REM
il faut de l'ordre de la fermeté et de
l'autorité voilà pour le d'aujourd'hui
pour demain il faudra pas se tromper de
diagnostic
c'est à dire
pas de réponse victimaire
c'est violent inouï
ça n'est pas
un cri de détresse
un appel à l'aide
et les eaux
sont certainement pas les déshérités de
la République la République depuis des
années déverses des milliards et des
milliards d'euros
dans ces quartiers là chaque de Maya
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire cette
réaction de Bruno Retailleau
dans son rôle d'un homme politique de
droite en appelant à l'ordre moi ce que
je dirais c'est que faut distinguer deux
choses très différentes il y a la
réponse aux émeutes je pense que il faut
que enfin il y a eu des infractions qui
ont été commises des interpellations
elle doit être jugée c'est une première
chose elle doit l'être de façon juste il
y a une deuxième chose qui est ce qui a
conduit aux émeutes et là je pense qu'il
faut si on parle d'autorité je pense
qu'il faut parler d'autorité juste c'est
à dire que
il faut pas penser l'intervention
policière comme étant uniquement fondé
sur la force si une police qui crée sa
légitimité uniquement sur l'utilisation
de la contrainte en étant extérieur au
quartier elle pour rebondir sur ce qui a
été dit précédemment elle peut réussir à
court terme parce qu'elle dit ben voilà
je suis forte je suis capable de lutter
contre la délinquance mais en même temps
elles savent les fondements de sa légit
moyen terme moi j'ai écouté beaucoup de
policiers est-ce qu'il y a un autre
choix quand on est confronté aux bandes
dont on parlait tout à l'heure il faut
avoir alors nous on est dans un modèle
de police très centralisé donc on n'est
pas
suffisamment soucieux des détails des
approches territoriales les approches
peuvent varier d'un territoire à l'autre
le niveau de gravité pas les mêmes les
alliés pour lutter contre les violences
sont pas les mêmes etc donc il faut
valoriser ces approches par le bas il
faut aussi valoriser pour une police qui
s'inscrit dans les territoires cette
capacité à avoir des partenaires la
police à l'agit pas seule elle agit avec
des travailleurs sociaux elle agit avec
des associations elle agit avec des
municipalités mais il faut aussi
s'inscrire dans la durée souvent quand
on pense les questions police on les
pense dans le court terme et il faut
réagir instantanément or si on a envie
d'avoir une logique de désescalade que
je le souligne que pratique la plupart
des pays
occidentaux équivalents c'est des
logiques qui s'inscrivent dans la durée
c'est à dire qu'on accepte de perdre la
court terme parce qu'on nous une
relation avec les gens et on s'inscrit
parce que bien évidemment ça se fait pas
facilement quand vous rentrez dans un
quartiers dans lequel vous ne rentrez
plus ou uniquement en force c'est pas
demain que vous allez entrer et avoir
une présence normale c'est que vous
allez avoir une stratégie de moyen terme
vous progressivement vous allez rendre
la présence policière acceptable être en
uniforme dans ces quartiers là
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile mais il
faut l'inscrire dans le moyen terme
j'entends cette cette ambition mais
est-ce que le climat politique français
Jean garrigue alors permet de la permet
de la mener d'une certaine façon très
intéressante en écoutant le discours de
Monsieur Retailleau qui finalement pas
si éloigné d'un discours qui était tenu
par des responsables du rassemblement
national et si vous le comparez à ce qui
a été l'intervention de Jacques Chirac à
la fin des émeutes de 2005 c'est pas du
tout le même discours discours de
Jacques Chirac en 2005 est un discours
qui se veut équilibré alors on dirait il
y avait eu l'état d'urgence avant pour
résoudre la crise bon mais ce discours
qui veut mettre fin à ces trois semaines
des meute c'est un discours où il dit
d'une part respecter les l'ordre répu
les lois de la République très bien
c'est ce que nous dit retaillons mais il
dit aussi repenser l'intégration
réfléchir à une intégration réussie etc
et cette cet aspect là cette équilibre
du discours vous le retrouvez plus
aujourd'hui dans le langage dans le
discours des hommes de la droite y
compris de la droite républicaine des
héritiers de Jacques Chirac et ça c'est
intéressant semble-t-il parce que ça
montre on parlait de radicalisation tout
à l'heure là aussi du côté si j'ai bien
entendu on va pas le réécouter mais il
dit dans un premier temps dans un
premier temps la réponse elle est
d'abord une réponse sécuritaire c'est
l'ordre public certes mais il manque me
semble-t-il ce petit supplément d'âme
qui était celui de Jacques Chirac en
même temps c'était il y a 18 ans et on
en est toujours à peu près au même alors
malgré le discours de Jacques Chirac
enfin vous voyez ce que non mais je
comprends très bien aussi que la donne a
changé les problèmes ce sont durci etc
mais c'est c'est intéressant vous
laissez cette évolution parce que vous
me posez la question du contexte
[Musique]
le problème quand un enfant de 12 ans
mais le feu a une école je pense que
c'est une question qui relève de
l'autorité parentale Mathieu ça fait
plusieurs jours depuis vendredi que
effectivement l'exécutif pointe cette
question de la responsabilité des
parents des plus jeunes et Métiers oui
et assez loin le premier a rappelé les
parents à leurs devoirs fuit Emmanuel
Macron vendredi matin mais depuis les
ministres lui ont allégrément emboîté le
pas comme Gérald Darmanin qu'on vient
d'entendre que et qui dit que la police
ne peut pas éduquer les enfants à la
place des parents ou encore et surtout
son collègue de la Justice Eric
Dupond-Moretti qui a donné tout le
week-end nous exigeons des parents
qu'ils tiennent leurs enfants il n'est
pas normal que des enfants traînent dans
les rues pour aller piller des magasins
et le Garde des Sceaux a rappelé même
que les parents au pas que les parents
que la justice peut garder soit rappelé
aux parents que la justice pourrait les
poursuivre pour défaillances dans
l'éducation ou la sécurité de l'enfant
et qu'il risque alors jusqu'à 30 000
euros d'amende voire deux ans
d'emprisonnement de parents responsables
on est donc passé assez vite à part en
coupable je vais dire en arrière de
temps et ses propos ont déclenché
évidemment un tollé à gauche notamment
vraiment où on a appelé que certains
parents en particulier dans les familles
monoparentales étaient dépassés par les
événements faute de moyens parce qu'à
pousser Éric Dupond-Moretti à préciser
sa pensée ce matin sur France Inter ceux
qui poussent des cris de frais
n'ont pas entendu ce que j'ai dit Madame
Salamé car j'ai dit bien sûr qu'il
n'était pas question d'ajouter de la
misère à la misère la maman qui
travaille la nuit pour nourrir sa
famille il est pas question d'aller
l'ennuyer mais ceux qui ont
responsabilité peuvent et c'est cela que
j'ai dit assurer l'autorité parentale et
qui ne le font pas soit par désinvolture
soit et c'est pire par intérêt je pense
que il faut quand même qu'on le rappelle
un certain nombre de choses il a raison
mais il y a dans l'argumentation de
l'exécutif une forme de rhétorique du
bon sens car tout le monde en découvrant
les images et l'âge de très jeunes de
certains émotices évidemment pour des
questions de savoir pourquoi ils étaient
dans la rue et où étaient leurs parents
on peut même se demander si ce rappel à
l'ordre n'a pas été d'une certaine façon
un des éléments qui peut expliquer que
la nuit dernière en tout cas il y a une
forme de de
plus calme que que les nuits précédentes
qui va payer pour tout ça c'est vos
daron vous avez entendu ces messages
influenceurs aussi ont beaucoup
alimenté les réseaux sociaux ce week-end
de fait je rappelle juste que l'article
1242 du Code civil engage bien la
responsabilité des parents pour réparer
les dommages causés par leurs enfants à
condition que ceci soit mineur que les
parents se concerne exerce bien
l'autorité parentale et que les enfants
vivent chez eux mais après c'est pas
aussi simple évidemment pas aussi simple
qu'une paire de claques comme l'a dit
aussi le préfet de l'Hérault ce matin il
suffit d'une bonne paire de claques dans
l'éducation c'est évidemment plus
compliqué et alors on parlait de de
réaction politique le rassemblement
national propose d'aller plus loin en
suspendant les allocations familiales
aux parents de mineurs récidivistes une
forme de double peine punir la petite
sœur pour un délit commis par son grand
frère ça n'a aucun sens ni aucune vertu
éducative c'est ajouter de la misère à
la misère pour reprendre l'expression
cité par la règle du pont mati voire du
ressentiment au ressentiment parce que
les ressorts de la délinquance juvénile
ne reposent pas seulement sur l'autorité
mentale c'est une clé mais c'est pas
toujours le fait de parents
démissionnaires c'est une spirale qui
est plus complexe je le disais j'ajoute
pour conclure qu'il y a une je trouve
qu'il y a une forme de rapport de classe
dans ces rapports à l'ordre parce que
quand il s'agit d'enfant de milieu aisés
on dit toujours en l'épouvre-parents ils
ont bien du mal avec leur fils quand il
s'agit d'enfants de milieu défavorisés
on dit ah bah les parents ils sont
incapables de tenir leur gamin dans le
premier cas on les plaint dans le second
on les stigmatise et dans les deux on ne
change souvent rien à faire alors votre
avis je commence avec vous
Thomas Sauvade est-ce qu'il faut
sanctionner financièrement les parents
d'enfants et Métiers franchement ça fait
partie de l'arsenal judiciaire qui doit
se déployer là effectivement il y a des
arguments pour il y a des arguments
contre passer une question compliquée et
j'ai pas de d'avis tranché mais je
trouve que sur les la focalisation sur
les parents sont bon je parle même pas
des jeux vidéo que c'est où là j'ai bon
la focalisation sur les parents oui elle
peut elle peut avoir un sens mais faut
pas qu'elle qu'elle soit la seule
question d'un gouvernement il y a eu ces
multifactoriel s donc il y a beaucoup
d'autres facteurs et là on a on a
vraiment un effet de communication très
fort sur la responsabilité parentale si
on va sur la responsabilité parentale
il faut déjà dire que au niveau des
noyaux durs au niveau des jeunes qui
sont dans les noyaux de genre dans les
banques dans les phénomènes de bandes
les plus durs qui sont en première ligne
vous avez des situations familiales
catastrophiques
le lien avec les parents il est très
largement rompu depuis longtemps on
pourrait développer mais on a vraiment
des parents voilà c'est pas seulement
parce qu'on parle souvent de la mer qui
travaille qui rentre et qui peut pas
mais c'est beaucoup plus que ça c'est
des situations d'abandon c'est des
situations de violence c'est l'absence
la de maîtrise de la langue française
c'est des parents qui connaissent pas du
tout leur environnement
beaucoup sont aussi primor arrivant et
sont complètement largués il y a des
micro-formes de contrôle social
communautaire qui des fois arrivent
entre maman de la même origine qui
arrive à travers des associations à
faire un peu de contrôle social etc mais
voilà c'est pour le noyau dur des bandes
c'est très très compliqué autre argument
la question des phénomènes de des
dynamiques de groupe font que les
parents forcément sont dépassés dire
qu'un adolescent un moment donné qui
claque la porte et qui va à Pablo
Picasso qui va dans des cités comme ça à
Nanterre à Saint-Ouen à Grenoble etc sur
des dynamiques de groupe il est
complètement embarqué et les adultes
sont dépassés et ça les enfants allez-y
les adolescents le voient très tôt que
quand il commence à sortir quand il
commence à rentrer dans ses groupes il
voit très tôt que ces groupes sont
beaucoup plus forts que leurs parents
mais oui mais malgré tout vous nous
l'avez dit vous-même c'est 10% d'une
d'une classe d'âge
dans une cité donc les les 90% d'autres
jeunes de la même classe dalle casque
d'âge est-ce qu'ils sont mieux tenus par
leurs parents est-ce que c'est parce
qu'ils ont une famille moins explosée
oui ce que je veux dire parce qu'on est
un peu toujours dans la dans la culture
de l'excuse donc il faut peut-être aussi
en sortir au niveau des au niveau des
des autres familles il y a notamment
deux stratégies parentales parce que
justement les parents ont peur notamment
pour leur fille et aussi
aussi pour leur garçon qui est les
mauvaises fréquentations et la vie dans
la rue la drogue la délinquance etc il y
a deux stratégies parentales classiques
on pourrait dire trois il y a la
religion avec des pratiques religieuses
très importantes avec une morale très
stricte très sévère qui met à distance
la drogue les mauvais comportements avec
un voilà donc il y a ce côté là il y a
le sport avec des parents qui vous
expliquent que ils ont alors vous les
retrouvez ensuite les ados à 18 ans avec
le médecin qui leur dit faut arrêter le
sport c'est parce que des problèmes par
exemple scoliose pour des filles qui
font de la gym etc donc des pratiques
sportives intensives qui nourrissent
d'ailleurs toutes les fédérations qui
alimentent toutes les fédérations de
sport avec les champions on peut avoir
dans différentes disciplines et puis
l'enfermement c'est pour ça que quand il
y a eu le confinement moi je parlais de
de confinement habituel pour pour
certains avec une une avec un équipement
dans la chambre personnel avec les jeux
vidéo
l'ordinateur etc et donc on garde
que l'enfant alors il faut avoir quand
même une chambre personnelle ce qui est
pas donné à tout le monde mais à partir
du moment il y en a qui ont une chambre
personnelle voilà c'est l'enfermement
dans dans la chambre Jacques de manière
un mot là-dessus parce qu'il nous reste
encore plein de thèmes dans ce débat qui
fitent vite sur les sanctions
financières visant les visant les
parents c'est une réponse simpliste et
une réponse binaire c'est une partie de
la réponse qu'est-ce que vous en dites
non c'est vraiment une réponse simpliste
dont on entend parler régulièrement
moi ça fait 20 ans que je l'entends ça
jamais été mis en place
c'est pour moi c'est vraiment du faux
bon sens
j'entendais le ministre qui disait
prouver la responsabilité des parents
comment est-ce qu'on la prouve comment
est-ce qu'on entre dans les détails
d'une vie familiale pour prouver les
responsabilités je trouve que c'est très
très compliqué je dis pas que les
parents n'ont pas de responsabilité
c'est pas du tout ça que je suis en
train de dire mais je trouve que c'est
pas positif du tout de l'aborder
maintenant parce que là c'est un
contexte où c'est d'abord et avant tout
culpabilisant pour les familles il y a
des responsabilité conjointe de
l'ensemble et surtout effectivement
cette a dit je crois très justement par
Thomas Sauvadet il y a quand même des
dynamiques de groupe de père
et pour rebondir sur ce que vous disiez
c'est à dire sur le la culture de
l'excuse ou parfois le misérabilisme y
compris des familles de classement
moyennes avec un haut niveau de diplôme
quand vous avez un enfant remuant un ado
remuant dans des dans des socialisations
entre père mais vous le tenez pas aussi
facilement que ça ce compte bien montrer
beaucoup de travaux de collègues sur la
désistance c'est que la désistance et
comment est-ce qu'on sort d'une
trajectoire délinquante ça s'inscrit
dans la durée mais ça se décrète pas
comme ça c'est quand on arrive à nouer
des relations plus positives avec
d'autres groupes de pairs mais voyez le
tout ça s'inscrit dans la durée mais je
trouve que actionner des des manettes
comme ça aussi simpliste me semble être
plus facteur d'effet pervers qu'autre
chose alors dans l'actualité de ce lundi
il y a aussi ces deux chiffres c'est
cagnotte donc vous avez certainement
entendu parler une cagnotte pour venir
en aide aux policiers incarcérés qui
dépassent et de loin le million d'euros
de promesses de dons à minuit 140000
euros au moment où on a voilà décidé de
caler cette infographie et une cagnotte
pour la famille de Naël qui est autour
de 230 000 euros Jean Gary que vous
inspire ces chiffres lors de la même
manière que ce questionnement sur la
responsabilité des parents peut être
légitime mais en réalité se résume à une
forme de posture politique qui s'adresse
aux plus grand nombre et aux besoins de
comparaison disant on va regarder soleil
s'occupe pas bien de leurs enfants mais
on voit bien que c'est très difficile de
de régler ça de la même manière ce qui
s'est passé pour la cagnotte celle de
pour le policier qui pour l'instant est
à cuire tout cas est mis en examen pour
éventuellement pour pour avoir tué un
jeune homme cette cagnotte là telle
qu'elle a été présentée pour le policier
est un geste est impact politique de
récupération politique par un militant
proche d'Éric Zemmour pour le citer
peut-être ces gens Messia qui détourne
totalement en réalité l'objet qui
pourrait être légitime d'une cagnotte de
ce type pour soutenir la famille de ce
policier dont la vie objectivement va
être brisé comme l'a été celle de la
famille du jeune homme cette famille
d'après ce que j'ai entendu est menacée
ils ont dû éventuellement déménager la
famille du policier est-ce que c'est ce
que c'est la rumeur est-ce que c'est la
réalité je sais pas encore mais en tout
cas ce pourrait être légitime donc vous
vous dites pourquoi pas une cagnotte
mais elle mais sont détournement par des
femmes politiques et présenter comme ça
c'est légitimer a priori ce qui n'a pas
encore été jugé le recours à une
violence létale et le recours au meurtre
de la part d'un fonctionnaire de police
et on sait très bien derrière ça il y a
cette forme d'impunité qu'on recherche
de clin d'oeil adressé à ces syndicats
de police les plus les plus extrêmes
bref on est dans quelque chose qui est
cette sorte d'intransigeance extrême de
sévérité extrême de de l'État face à ce
que le l'un des représentants de du
rassemblement national appelé les hordes
de barbares quand même donc ce
vocabulaire là il est quand même
intéressant à analyser donc si vous
voulez pour moi ça c'est quelque chose
qui est dangereux Thomas SODET est-ce
qu'elle est indécente cette cagnotte il
va falloir du policier je je sais pas je
pense la question différemment est-ce
que c'est le ferment de on parlait de la
difficulté de renouer des liens entre
une partie de la jeunesse la police etc
est-ce que c'est le ferment de de haine
future vous voyez ce que je veux dire
je sais pas je sais que c'est les deux
policiers ont des états de service très
brillants l'un a été décoré parce qu'il
est intervenu notamment au Bataclan en
je sais que intervenir au quotidien dans
ces quartiers c'est être soumis à un
stress et un niveau de tension et un
processus d'accumulation de la violence
c'est voir aussi des collègues gravement
blessés pour avoir fait des formations
avec des policiers avec des gendarmes
ils ont eux aussi
leur mort leur blessés graves qu'il
n'oublie pas donc très sincèrement je je
suis triste à la fois pour le policier
et pour sa famille et pour Naël et sa
famille 700 membres des forces de
l'ordre blessés depuis le le début de
ces émeutes depuis un peu moins d'une
semaine et là aussi on a comparé avec
les chiffres de 2005 puisqu'on cherche à
évaluer un peu les différences il y en
avait eu 224 pendant trois semaines donc
on est face à des forces de l'ordre qui
sont en en première ligne et tiens je
vous propose d'écouter
Frédéric pechnarch et l'ancien directeur
de la police nationale qui est
aujourd'hui président du parti LR en
Île-de-France alors lui il mettait en
avant
depuis 5-6 jours des meute le sang froid
des policiers je trouve que les
policiers des gendarmes se conduisent de
manière absolument remarquable j'étais
avec le ministre intérieur le préfet de
police le maire du 17e arrondissement
Geoffroy Boulard samedi soir en
rencontre des policiers qui allaient
intervenir dans la nuit sur le terrain
qui avait déjà fait trois nuits j'ai
trouvé des gens résolus calme sérieux
faisant leur travail donc je pense que
les policiers et les gendarmes peuvent
aller encore beaucoup plus loin dans la
difficulté même si il faut reconnaître
que la période est particulièrement
difficile et si vous reprenez sur
quelques années les gilets jaunes les
attentats
Jacques de Maillard c'est ce qu'on peut
on peut sous soulever ça c'est vrai que
on craignait tous quand on a commencé à
discuter de ce qui allait se passer dans
les dans les jours dans les nuits qui
ont suivi la mort de de Naël on
craignait tous qui est d'autres
faits similaires qui puissent se passer
et là on a on a des policiers très
nombreux policiers gendarmes très
nombreux 45000 tous les soirs qui
réussissent et on va croiser les doigts
que ça continue à mener des
interpellations qui se passent dans des
conditions on va dire normalement vous
disiez la police française souvent
montrée du doigt à l'international là on
peut lui donner insatisfait site ou
c'est trop tôt pour le faire mais après
c'est sans doute trop tôt parce qu'on
n'a pas tout mais de fait on est sur une
matière qui est particulièrement
inflammable donc on a vécu 4 jours où
les potentiels des rives étaient
nombreuses d'un côté comme de l'autre et
de fait ça c'est quand même plutôt
atténué peut-être pas apaisé mais
atténuer dans la prudence ce soir
de déployer mais ça s'est pas traduit
par une accentuation donc ça c'est c'est
un élément important et les policiers
les gendarmes sont quand même intervenus
dans des conditions qui ont été
particulièrement difficiles et ça il
faut le il faut le relever 700 membres
des forces de l'ordre qui ont été
blessés c'est quand même absolument
considérable
réel il y a un policier qui s'en est
rendu compte d'ailleurs le lendemain
matin en reprenant son gilet par balle
il a trouvé une voilà alors je sais plus
quel calibre c'était mais enfin voilà on
lui a tiré dessus au niveau de l'abdomen
donc tout à fait donc c'est vrai que
quand on le rapporte à la situation plus
structurelle on a souligner tout à
l'heure les tensions qui existaient au
quotidien entre jeunes et police ça
renvoie quand même une dimension très
importante et qui plaide je sais que
c'est pas facile à court terme mais qui
plaide pour un apaisement dans la durée
une des escalade c'est que quand c'est
difficile c'est dur pour les policiers
eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire que les policiers
eux-mêmes travaillent dans des
conditions qui sont exposées difficiles
et souvent ça se sont des spirales qui
s'auto alimentent quand vous rentrez
dans un quartier en ayant peur vous
pensez d'abord et avant tout à vous
protéger et donc quand vous pensez
d'abord avant tout à vous protéger vous
pensez pas à aller voir les gens pour
échanger avec eux et donc cette
dynamique de dégradation elle est à la
fois négative pour les policiers et pour
les habitants de ces quartiers là et
donc ça plaise vraiment pour en profiter
pour lancer une dynamique beaucoup plus
positive de renforcement des relations
Jean Gary finalement le point de départ
de ces émeutes c'est la mort de Naël et
c'est la question de l'usage de l'arme
par des policiers dans dans un cas de
refus de d'obtempérer
ce débat là il est il est balayé par les
violences est-ce qu'il faudra le reposer
est-ce qu'il faudra le remettre sur la
table oui il faut forcément d'autant
plus que on a l'impression que la loi de
2017 sous dans un contexte qui était
celui de l'entité terrorisme islamique
cette loi a renforcé à augmenter le
nombre des victimes dans ces cas de
refus d'obtempérer donc forcément je
pense qu'il faut y réfléchir mais il
réfléchir dans un cadre plus large que
dont vous parlez c'est-à-dire de cette
désescalade de ce de se rapprochement en
parlant aussi de la police de proximité
peut-être en parlant aussi de la manière
dont l'IGPN la police des polices pour
être plus détachée du reste de
l'institution pour ne pas encourir le
risque de la
délégitimations ou le risque d'être trop
indulgentes avec les policiers pris en
faute enfin bref il y a plusieurs
aspects comme ça qui qui je pense
pourrait contribuer à une forme de de
désescalade et surtout ne pas tomber
dans ces postures dont on parlait tout à
l'heure parce que pour revenir au thème
de la cagnotte au fond moi j'aurais très
bien compris une cagnotte je répète pour
la famille de ce policier voire même une
sorte de cagnotte dommage pour les pour
tous les policiers morts en service et
Dieu sait que qu'ils ont payé un lourd
tribu mais là c'est
ce type de récupération et de l'autre
côté ceux qui ont profité de ce de ce
drame pour flétrir et pour pour dire que
toute la police était raciste ou était
ou tu es enfin vous vous souvenez de la
phrase donc Mélenchon la police tue de
tout ça si vous voulez
corrompre pourris un débat qui devrait
être le plus comment dirais le plus
objectif possible le plus complexe
possible parce que les solutions en
l'occurrence elles sont très très
complexes très très différents et sont
si bien sociologiques culture Israël que
économique enfin bref merci beaucoup
merci à tous Jean Gary que j'appelle le
titre de votre livre Olivier contre
Matignon qui est publié aux éditions
Talandier et puis je l'avais pas en
ouverture du débat avec de Mayer mais
vous publiez police et société en France
aux éditions au presse 2 Sciences Po
merci encore à tous d'avoir participé à
ce débat je vous dis à bientôt sur sur
Public Sénat voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à toutes et à tous de
votre fidélité vous pouvez retrouver
tous nos programmes sur la plateforme
public sénat.fr et puis notez l'invité
de la matinale demain on parlait de
Dominique Faure tout à l'heure Mathieu
la ministre de l'église chargé des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité on parlera évidemment de la
protection des élus bonne soirée à
toutes et à tous